c'est un endroit que daniela connaît
trop bien son banque personnel où elle
se réfugie lors des alertes de plus en
plus fréquente aux raids aériens
elle est de retour chez elle depuis peu
après deux semaines d'exil en pologne
elle a inscrit ses filles de 15 ans et
de 7 ans à l'école à cracovie puis elle
a écouté son coeur qui lui disaient de
rentrer en ukraine
en prenant le thé avec elle ne lui dit
pas qu'elle a posé un geste courageux
elle veut simplement aider les réfugiés
qui ont besoin d'être trouvé du renfort
pour les bénévoles à bout de souffle en
plus de poursuivre son travail habituel
d'orthodontie sts
2000 à shaw cole n'a pas eu de mal à
s'en casser les
jabots de l'action
[Musique]
aussi a senti l'appel de la patrie en
elle une fois sa mère et sa fille de 6
ans victoria bien en sécurité et à
l'abri à cracovie elle est revenue à
lever coup du hasard sur le chemin du
retour on lui a demandé de diriger le
département des communications de lviv
en temps de guerre
wimdu
[Musique]
le coup d'éclat des poussettes vide pour
représenter la centaine d'enfants
ukrainiens morts depuis l'invasion russe
a fait le tour du monde c'est une idée
de svetlana elle germé dans sa tête
depuis quelques semaines
la voulais montrer l'ampleur du désastre
causé par l'évasion et forcer les
puissances mondiales à appuyer l'ukraine
même si elle dit qu'il n'ya aucune place
à l'émotion et qu'elle doit se dédier
entièrement à son pays suit de là nous
fait écouter un message de sa fille
l'implorant de la retrouver rapidement
elle reçoit cinq ans messages par jour
de sa petite victoria des messages
difficile pour le coeur d'une mère aussi
dédié à une cool soit elle
[Musique]
dans le sous sol de daniela les marques
des heures passées dans son abri
antibombes un rappel selon elle que la
guerre se poursuit et que son pays a
besoin d'elle ici philippe blet radio
canada vivent en ukraine
[Musique]